[Musique]
et on commence ces informations
grégoryie par la première ministre qui
était en visite dans les ivelines
aujourd'hui elliizabeth borne s'est
rendue à maniléamoau elle était
accompagnée de Charlotte cobel
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'enfance
pour une visite et du Collège Albert
Einstein l'établissement est engagé dans
la lutte contre le cyberhcèlement au
travers du programme pix des élèves de
6e sont formés tout au long de l'année
pour obtenir un passeport numérique la
première ministre a d'ailleurs pu
échanger avec ses jeunes le cyber
harcèlement toucherait 25 % des
collégiés en France selon la Direction
Générale de l'Enseignement scolaire il y
a de semaine le gouvernement a détaillé
les contours de son plan contre le
harcèlement scolaire après le suicide du
jeune Nicolas poissi il y a du nouveau
dans le procès de l'attentat de
Magnanville la réclusion perpétuelle la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité avec
une peine de 22 ans de sûreté c'est ce
qui est requis contre Mohamed lbin
aberous c'est ce qui donc c'est l'homme
qui est jugé pardon par par la Cour
d'Assise spéciale de Paris pour
complicité d'assassinat au nom de l'État
islamique il est accusé d'avoir été
présent sur les lieux de l'attentat le
13 juin 2016 Jessica Schneider et
Jean-Baptiste Salvin un couple de
policiers avaiit été assassinés à leur
domicile de Magnanville sous les yeux de
leur enfant à leors âgé de 3 ans
l'accusation contre Mohamed lamid
aberous repose notamment sur une trace
ADN retrouvée sur le repose-poignet de
l'ordinateur portable des victimes même
si lui réfute toute présence sur place
il est le seul accusé dans ce procès
puisque le terroriste avait été abattu
dans l'assau du Red pour libérer
l'enfant du couple verdict attendu
demain à poiss l'inauguration du campus
PSG est reportée elle devait avoir lieu
cet automne mais elle est finalement
reprogrammée au printemps 2024 la
direction veut que toute la famille
pariss-germain soit réunie pour
l'événement le groupe professionnel
masculin a bien pris ses quartiers
depuis juillet mais l'équipe féminine et
les jeunes du centre de formation et de
préformation doivent arriver sur place
seulement en janvier après la fin de
nouveaux travaux suivront à l'horizon
2026 l'équipe de handbal et les judoca
du PSG le chantier du gymnase et du dojo
sera lancé l'année prochaine et la
construction d'un stade de 3000 places
reste toujours en suspend même si un
permis de construire a été déposé et
enfin c'est officiel le vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Eveline va
accueillir un nouvel événement sportif
et c'est une première Mathilde il s'agit
des championnat de France de BMX
Freestyle qui se tiendront les 9 et 10
décembre prochain avec la présence des
meilleurs riders français en pleine
préparation olympique et des
championnats qui concernent deux
disciplines du freestyle le parc et le
flat est-ce que vous savez en plateau la
différence entre BMX flat BMX parc alors
là non pas du tout alors il s'agit de
faire des figures sur un BMX ça pour les
deux c'est vrai mais il y a quelques
petites différences et notamment pour le
parc qui s'effectue ces sessions
s'effectuent dans un skate park sur des
rampes par exemple BMX Park sera au
programme des Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 avec des des épreuves place de la
Concorde à Paris ce qui ne sera pas le
cas du BMX flat qui sera donc non
présent au joio le principe de cette
discipline c'est que les figures
s'exécutent directement euh sur le plat
comme vous le voyez à l'image justement
pas de rampe donc pour ces championnats
de France 3000 spectateurs sont attendus
le prix du billet est 10 € pour un jour
15 € pour les deux jours avec des
réductions possibles si vous êtes
licencié de la Fédération française de
cyclisme ou tout simplement habitant de
50 el et bien merci beaucoup Grégory
canalé pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une information ou une image près
de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7weet news